[Music]
singer actress and activist Janelle
Monae is a big supporter of the times of
movement she's getting more attention
for her latest album it's called dirty
computer it's good - a reference to
people's imperfections it challenges
social norms and traditional concepts of
a woman's role in the world CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Anthony Mason
both know Monet at vandal here in New
York City about her latest project
Anthony good morning to you good morning
Janelle monáe's latest project is
encouraging Millennials to vote for her
it's a tribute to her grandmother who
didn't always have that right growing up
in the South you made a pretty strong
statement on this record thank you
[Music]
one of the things that was most
important to me was to make sure that I
was coming from a very honest place
you know it's an album to really
celebrate those that I felt needed to be
celebrated most those in marginalized
communities dirty come view
you feel marginalized as an artist I've
had lots of opportunities to travel and
go see the world but when I take off my
makeup when I take off my outfit you
know I'm still Janelle Monae Robinson
who grew up in Kansas City Kansas to
working-class parents so being a young
black queer woman in America at any
moment you know I could have my rights
taken away from me
[Music]
how did you arrive at that expression
because I love that expression dirty
computer well dirty computers are
inspiring to me people say that these
dirty computers these humans have these
bugs and these viruses the things that
make them unique are looked at as
negatives but dirty computers look at
their their bugs and their viruses as
attributes as features as added value to
this country to the society it's just
saying that I'm a dirty computer but I
too am American while Janelle Monae is
speaking out on her album we have the
power to change the world she's
encouraging her fans to as well through
voting in a video she's made for the
group when we all vote imagine if that
7% showed up hmm really about just
making sure that our generation is
activated that we're fired up ready to
go and we're ready to vote
my grandmother was a sharecropper in
aberdeen mississippi and she didn't have
the opportunity to vote I just made a
promise to her that when I became 18 and
I had the right to exercise my power I
would do that in her honor and even
though I could be in another city during
a concert I will fly back to make sure
that I vote well I'll tell you what a
beginning in 2016 Monay earned a claim
as an actress in Oscar favorites hidden
figures ladies
is a god-ordained miracle and moonlight
stop putting your hair down in my house
you know my rule was all love and all
pride in this house but her true passion
is music that's just the way you make me
so you first came to New York to go to
school yes which she first realized when
she moved from Kansas to New York City
to study musical theater I studied for
about a good year year and a half and
then I realized that I wanted to tell my
story I wanted to sing my own songs I
had so much bubbling in here that I
didn't feel like I was able to get out
and through her songs she shares her
deeply personal story how do you feel
about the response you've gotten to it
overwhelming in the best possible way I
have a fear of is this gonna connect is
this gonna resonate
I know that it means something to me and
to show up and go city to city country
to country and see people singing the
word some times louder than me like it's
so hard to describe that feeling
[Music]
because it's been a dream to have your
work resonate with people's hearts and
their souls in the way that it is 30
computers are great I'm getting a lot of
Grammy buzz and her acting career is
still in full force she said she just
landed a supporting role in this
upcoming biopic on Harriet Tubman so
she's got a lot going on he's speaking
out more now than ever before is true if
you sit down and talk to us so you
really liked her yes extremely talented
got a lot to say yeah company it's
always great to have you thank you